hello everyone um okay today we're gonna
be talking about some of my favorite
debugging tools um the idea is you kind
of have this like Swiss Army knife
except there are no sharp objects on it
um I'm except some of them turn out to
be sharp objects anyway um another
opening slide I have for this talk is
Linux debugging tools you'll love which
involves you talking to a charming
penguin about network packets so um this
is like there's a lot of programming
languages stuff at this conference right
and there's this question of like okay
well so I'm not gonna talk about
programming languages at all first but
like one thing that like Haskell and
like Fortran have in common is that like
when they talk to each other they might
all talk using a computer network right
and they're always using TCP and so kind
of a common theme to everything I'm
going to be talking about today is
everything I'm going to be doing is
stuff you can use on any programming
language um and we're going to be
talking about like the interfaces that
program programming for Graham programs
use to talk to each other so kind of a
setting for this is sometimes I'll log
into a computer and something will be
like terribly wrong right it'll be like
boom today is an exciting day for you
and you're like what's happening and um
one thing that I'm really starting to
learn um and to try to believe in is
that like all bugs are sort of easy to
solve um and I don't mean this in this
way like this is easy what do you think
it's hard um but fundamentally like if
you can figure out what's going on and
if you have like the right tools to look
at it you're like oh I see
I sent like panda instead of cat and it
was supposed to be cat I get it like um
and if you have the right tools
everything gets a lot easier to do um
sometimes I think you just have this
idea of debugging like I just needed to
you're really smart and stare at the
code and think really hard and be like I
am a genius
um which happens occasionally but not
that often um it's much better to have
the right tools um and in particularly
if you're like not scared to like kind
of like delve into what's happening I'm
with your code and like keep on like
uncovering further layers of abstraction
until you find out the real problem it
can be really valuable
um so instead of the normal ways of
debugging where you read the code I knew
at the front statements and he knew the
language we're instead she's gonna be
Wizards these are some of our magical
toolkit we're gonna talk about estrellas
Wireshark perf net said it's gonna be
the best if you don't know what these
things are good
please stay because I'm gonna tell you
about them um and the kind of
conversation that we're going to be
having in this talk is the conversation
where you're like Hello which files when
I program open and the operating system
will be like it was wrong doc text and
you're like oh well I can fix that I'll
just open right down text and said um so
it's like you're having a conversation
with your operating system about what
your program is doing um so this talk is
going to be we're gonna do three
mysteries on mysteries are easier to
solve you invented them yourself so
we're gonna be able to solve all of them
we have the cases than the get missing
configuration file
um the case of a slow program and the
case of the French website um and then
there's going to be some extra stuff at
the end depending on how many minutes we
have more minutes more stuff okay
so let's do the case of the missing
configuration file one thing that often
happens to me is I'll write a
configuration file and I'll start my
program and it does not work right um
and it could either not work because I
did the wrong thing or because I edited
the wrong file who's ever edited file
and it was wrong like all of you perfect
right um but like how do you know write
a really classic example of this is bash
RC versus brass profile right it's like
if you edit bash RC how do you know if
it was the right thing it's confusing
idk I'm actually I guess I know now like
sometimes you can learn over time but
like what if you don't know um you could
read the documentation but that's boring
um so instead we're gonna use s trace
which is literally my favorite program
in the world um as some of you may know
I have an ester sticker on my phone it's
a whole thing anyway um so um s trace is
a program with traces system calls right
I always like to explain what it's just
in Pawleys because when I didn't know it
was a bad time
life okay so the way system call works
is you have like a proper gentleman
I guess who's like please can you open
this file and then your operating system
on the other side operating system to
know about all kinds of wonderful things
and particularly they know how to open
files they know what the hard disk is my
program does not know what a hard disk
is really it just like please file
Thanks so your operating system via file
and then your programming program last
things like please read some bytes from
the file um the you notice that I
underlined in red I'm open and read
that's because open and read our system
calls and two of the most important ones
so the way you run s race is you take s
trace and you were on your program like
bash I asked it to just tell me about
opens which is what this - 'flag does um
and then it was like oh you opened it -
RC and I'm like perfect
it was bash RC done right now I know in
at least when I ran back that time that
it only read this file and it did not
read off bash profile so if I edited up
bash profile it can't possibly work
because that file never even gets opened
and then I'm done I don't need to read
any stupid documentation um who wants to
do that right it's not fun um I want to
show you a little demo of s trace
because it can be a little scary so it
looks like this usually if this is like
totally understandable to you I'll raise
your hand so some of you some you're
like I get that um yeah so wonderful
thing to remember a test race is just
like that if you don't understand
everything it's ok I'm just like use a
craft judiciously and you'll be able to
figure out what's going on a lot of the
time it's ok if you don't know what like
70 like almost system calls are ok um so
we won I'm an important thing to know
about s race is a committee of program
I'm 50 times slower don't run it on your
production database that would be bad
that's what you need to know um these
are some of my favorite system calls I'm
executive yi is a really great system
call it means when you're running a
program I'm so one really cool thing
that happened uh I think my first day at
work I my current job like two and half
years ago is we had this script and the
script was running a lot of commands and
was running the wrong commands and it
was this Ruby script and I didn't want
to read
because it was boring um it's like who
wants to read the code so we ran Esther
a Sumer like hey yesterday he's just
like tell us all the all the commands
you ran and he just told me all the
commands that I ran and I was like oh
that one was wrong
should have been different and then like
we could really instantly see what was
wrong right instead of having to like
read ruby ruby is fine okay so so you
can read or write files you can start
programs and you can do like network
activity right you'd be like this this
is the server that I'm connecting to and
there are lots of other system calls
that I love but these are some of my
favorites um there are a lot of really
good flags um you can write output to a
file you can say like follow every other
sub process ever and you're just like
Esther is this one program you can print
the time that every system call get
executed um it's really great I like it
so much that I've seen about it about
how much I like it two years ago
um you can download it and print it on
my website if you want or you can just
read it okay right oh yeah
so I said that Esther is really slow um
another thing that you can use if you
don't want to use Astraeus because it's
too slow um is this thing called open
snip which is new as of Linux 4.4 I'm
gonna show you like a little demo of how
you use open smooth it's just a script
um I just learned like pseudo open
sitive and then we're just gonna see
what files everything open on my
computer right now oh man what's
happening who knows right it's a Google
Chrome Google Chrome is doing something
browser blocking what's that I don't
know um so this is kind of fun this is
program but just showed you what
programs are being opened um you can
also tell it like I'm only interested in
like one like you tell like you're just
interested in like one specific program
I'm gonna and then it'll just show you
what files that's opening I mean open
stuff is good because it's fast and s.vs
slow um and if you go to this github
repo you can find out how to get it um
but it only works on pretty new kernels
okay um it works using something called
ebps I'm Brendan drag racer Laura blog
where he's basically like so excited
about EVPs if you want to know about it
more about it you should read his blog
and then you'll be excited too okay
next up is the case of the flow program
so we have a three still around three
one is slow because it's using too much
CPU time one is slow because it's
writing too much let's disk and the last
one is slow because it's waiting for a
slow server and we don't know which one
is which I mean I do but you don't
and there are called things like mystery
one mystery two and mystery three and we
are not going to figure out which ones
they are by reading the source code
we're going to figure out which ones
they are by being wizards obviously
because that's the whole point of this
talk um okay so I'm gonna run they're
all faith on programs um I ran Python
mystery 1wi um and I read this room
called time which tells you a how long
in program took and be sort of where it
spent its time um so the interesting
thing about this program is that it's
spent five percent of his time on the
CPU right which means that 95 percent of
time it was waiting what are you waiting
for
I don't know um so what we're gonna do
here is we're going to look into the
Linux kernel Seoul it turns out that
this is a really easy thing to do um
which really surprised me so what you do
is you find out the PID of your process
in this case my process was three one
seven two eight and I was like what is
the Linux kernel stack right now for
this process right and this is something
you just go look at it's no big deal um
this is a lot of stuff on the screen so
if we erase most of it you're like oh
tcp received message i know what that is
tcp is like networking and stuff right
great it was the network it was waiting
for some kind of network stuff
idk right um but we now know so much
more we didn't need to read what the
program was doing at all and that's
amazing
um I have the server which is just like
sleep to return hi which is why I took 2
seconds cuz it just like hangs out for
two seconds before doing anything
perfect so that was super easy to do we
just needed to know that the Linux
kernel will just tell you what it's
doing okay mystery program number two um
this one took two point seven four
seconds and it spent 99% of its time on
the CPU this one is like not really a
big mystery but I wanted to point out
that like not all problems can be
solved by doing this kind of like by
looking at system calls cuz if you're on
the CPU you're just like adding stuff up
for something right the operating system
doesn't carry other than like it just
needs to schedule you to run on the CPU
um so here's use a Python profiler right
I don't know what's wrong with you okay
and in fact what this program was doing
is it just adding up 14 million numbers
which in python takes two point seven
four seconds which you might interpret
as either computers are faster slow um
depending on how you feel about how long
it should take to add up 14 million
numbers I have have a little game anyway
forego number three I'm programmed
number three is it says oops
94% so you might be like Julia
ninety-four percent is basically the
same in 99 percent this is the same as
before and I would be like good
observation but you're wrong the reason
that you're wrong is that it splits up
the amount of CPU time into user space
time and operating system time and this
is kind of interesting right so it's not
really spending any time in user space
so the program itself isn't doing
anything but the operating system is
spending all this time doing stuff what
is it doing what's happening why um
we're gonna start up everything dee set
uh which is one of my favorite things to
run um and what DISA does is it prints
out how much like disk and network and
CPU you're using every second I have
this demo slide cuz I'm supposed to do
demo now oh no okay so I'm gonna start
this and then I'm gonna run you set
really fast and then hopefully it'll
have worked yeah totally okay cool um so
this is printing out I'm this read and
write in the middle there let me close
this and then I can point the stuff but
before it goes off the screen no control
C control C okay so in this right column
here um you can see that it like wrote
for 55k 200 megabytes 300 megabytes 300
megabytes and then it stopped writing
stuff so like somehow we instantly know
what this program is doing alright this
program is writing stuffs discs and like
we don't care that it was written in
Python alright we know that error
through him
megabytes diskette seconds um so that's
cool right like we've already learned a
lot um
buts what was what's with the CPU usage
it's not that hard to write stuff to
disk
is it why would it be so hard what's
wrong with you so you might know who
uses top to figure out what's what's
taking up the time on their computers um
uses the H top edge stuff is really cool
and I love it um who uses perfect ah
perfect ah Piz one of my favorite things
and we're going to talk about it now
perf top is something that you use on
linux i'm purpose a program you can
install and basically what it does is it
can tell you which functions are running
slowly on your computer so instead of
which programs which functions inside
those programs just kind of crazy right
so I'm gonna start first off right now
and yeah okay and then I'm gonna run my
program and we're gonna see what happens
okay cool that's happening so look up
there you see AES and I Anquan and
equipped FS right begin right it's
happening something's happening
what does it mean but so we received the
everybody have a clue that right we have
an amazing clue which we did not have
before about why our program is slow I
copied this here to make it bigger um so
what does a yes mean encryption it means
encryption I was writing this file to my
home directory my home directory is
encrypted so it's a lot of work for it
to write to my home directory um which
is really interesting right it's like
suddenly writing to disk is not easy
anymore if you're writing to an
encrypted filesystem fascinating um okay
new mystery a case of the French website
I live in Montreal - the bilingual city
um so if you go to a website it could
show up neither language right and like
how does it know what language should
show up in um no no I lost my slides
whatever that's fine
they're here anyway I'm so prepared ok
so I have this website on my computer
right now
and if I go to it in my browser it says
hello welcome strangelet yay everything
is amazing
um if I go to it in my terminal what why
doesn't it work then it hits me is that
what's happening let's find out what's
happening okay now it works no problem
um so if I go do it if I get it with
curl in my terminal then it's in French
right but this is the same website right
it's an English here and it's in French
here so like what's happening why is it
doing this I don't know
I'm upset so um what it what I do find
out is this is programmable pantograph
um and graph lets you grep is great for
your network literally um so grabs which
is a file and grep searches your network
and i'm just gonna print out some of the
network packets on my local network so i
start printing stuff out right now
there's nothing happening so it doesn't
print anything great um something
happened let's ignore that that's not
important um okay and now you can see
like Banjul behavior a strange loop
right i'm has happened and then i'm
gonna load it in my browser and then we
can see that it says hello welcome
strangely okay so that was the response
here right this thing is the response
but what was the request so this is the
browser request and this one here is the
this is the curl request right so it's a
get HTTP 1.1 host local host ugh and
curl blah blah blah and then google
chrome set a lot of stuff right so cruel
so just like website please and curl was
like I had Google Chrome was like I have
a lot of things to say about how I would
like this website um one thing it
specifically said about how it would
like this website is it said accept
language en us so it said that it would
like the website in English okay cool I
can do that I can ask for a website in
English right why this is website hate
me now
I don't know we would debug that but we
will not
oh it crashed why did it crash that's so
interesting
no not interesting in the middle of demo
computer okay great uh-huh
we're not worrying about the crashing
web server which is yet another mystery
we're gonna get the website and now you
can see the website in English because I
asked for it in English um and so this
was kind of fun right
feels like often do like programs are
deterministic great well they're not
deterministic for their logical and
generally they respond to the inputs you
give them so if you just look over the
zip it's are sometimes you can figure
out why they're at wrong great how are
we for time perfect amazing we're
exactly where I hoped we would be okay
so and the next thing I want to do is
talk about perf perfect for Graham for
Linux that I think is really kind of
like tragically misunderstood the reason
is tragically misunderstood is that it's
pretty badly documented and it's hard to
figure out what it does
um it does a lot of different things and
it's in general a tool that you can use
for performance analysis and kind of the
reason I think that perf is interesting
is like well it's pretty useful right
like you can run perfect op on your
computer to like to debug your programs
you can especially do that if they're
written in C um you all might be like I
don't write and C why should I care an
exciting thing about perf and perf top
is that you can use it to debug your
programs also if they're in Java or a
node so there's a program called like
Java math agent which can tell you which
will like tell you actually which Java
functions are running on your computer
like through perf and note has kind of
the same thing and I think like this
idea that you can just like always see
what's happening but in your program at
any given time it's like really powerful
and it makes you want to build but for
other like programming languages they
don't have this anyway but what's perf
how does it work
it has three different kinds of things
that it does one of them is it has
hardware counters which I'm going to
explain it has a sampling profiler which
is what we've been looking at right and
it lets you trace thanks um so I want to
talk for a second about sampling versus
tracing
um so sampling is when you have a
program that's kind of slow you want to
know why I need to take a bunch of
little snapshots right so you're like
okay you're running this like encryption
function okay you're running the
encryption function okay you're running
the encryption function okay your enemy
encrypted okay okay okay you're like I
guess it's just all the encryption
function all the time right um so you
don't keep track of every single thing
the program does but you take samples
often enough that you can get a really
good picture of what's happening
um and this is the way a lot of
profilers work um and it's like
incredibly incredibly useful um so but
sometimes you have something that
happens pretty infrequently um so I used
to think that if something happened like
0.1 percent at the time 0.1 percent at
the time a lot thinks it's a lot not
many of you some of you think it's a lot
um
so sometimes it's not a lot like you're
about 1% at the time it's like one in a
thousand times and if you work on like a
little a little small thing on that not
a lot of people use maybe that means it
happens like once every few days and
doesn't really matter but if you have
billions of things then one in a
thousand times is a million times right
and so if something happens billions of
times a day and it's broken your part
one person at the time it means it's
broken a million times a day right and
that can be really bad and the bad thing
about sampling profilers is that
something that's happening kind of
infrequently
you'll often miss it and so it's really
important to have tracing tools because
tracing tools our tools that tell you
everything that's happening right so
you're like every time this weird thing
happens tell me everything about it and
this is why I love log files this is why
I love tracing systems and then you can
be like okay this thing happened only
four times but all of those four times
I'm like really concerned about and I
want to know everything about that um
and I used to spend a long time trying
to debug things with a sampling profiler
which would just show me like the
general distribution when what I needed
to be doing was using a tracing tool um
so it's important to know which one is
which um okay we're gonna start out by
talking about Hardware counters so which
are another different thing entirely
okay
so I think this is really fun to know
about um I'm mostly right Ruby this is
not that important if you write Ruby but
I think it's good to know that how fast
computers really are um Dan and it's
going to yell at me because I'm gonna
get this wrong okay um so your CPU is
right next to a cache called the l1
cache
um which is extremely close to it and it
takes about like 0.5 nanoseconds I'm to
get something from the l1 cache um it
takes like 200 times longer just like
this like yawn of time it's gets around
and if you're working on a program
that's really performance if you
actually care about this um and so three
years ago someone was telling me they're
like Julia it's important to use your
caches efficiently you know and I was
like how do you know if you're using
like this is this like tiny thing inside
my CPU like where even is it I can't see
it right like how am I supposed to know
if I'm using my l1 cache this is stupid
like this is not helpful this is just
like some weird abstract idea it turns
out that um it's not a weird abstract
idea and you can actually know exactly
how many times your l1 cache is being
used I'm really really easily using perf
um and oh yeah there's this great thing
called latency numbers every programmer
should know which you can read and try
to remember
I cannot remember these numbers really
but I try to read it every so often I'm
like yeah ok read one megabyte
sequential in disk ok 20 milliseconds ok
it's kind of hard but it's good - it's
good to think of it um ok um and the way
you can read figure out about your l1
cache misses as you can use per stat and
you're just like hey perf um tell me how
many l1 cache load misses LS had when it
ran it and it's like forty thousand
seven hundred fifty-seven and you're
like okay great and like the reason I
think this is interesting is not because
this is something I use every day um but
I find it really helpful to remember
that like my computer is really fast and
has all this really smart stuff in it
and I'm like okay if I ever need to know
about how my l1 cache works like or like
how to optimize that that's like some
foot that's somewhere I can go right and
these tools are available and this stuff
is happening I'm I can
um and it's like it is ran in 0.004
seconds and I'm like okay there's no
problem okay I do not need to optimize
this cool um so we know hardware
counters um let's talk a little bit
about the sampling profiler do I have so
much time yeah I can maybe even talk
about how it works okay cool
so Perez assembling profiler which is
what happens when you run perf top so
what you do is you say hey please perf
record this function right I'm - G is
extremely important to apply for if it
means you collect like the full stack
trace and it makes really big difference
when you're trying to debug um so you
want to record what's happening um and
the way this works is there's this like
subsystem in the Linux kernel which will
like when your program is stopped like
collect information about what it's
doing and then like send you the
information i'm so there's actually like
a ton of work that went into like making
this a thing and it will create this
file called proof data um after its
recorded recorded all this sapling
information and then you'd ask it for a
report you're like what were you doing
fine what was going on man and it's like
they're right just get dense um and so I
find get dense kind of hilarious because
it's always like it's like a dentist I
don't know um but it means directory
entries to spending a lot of time doing
things like like going through
directories and figuring out what's
inside them and going over them I think
you like encrypt FS read dear um so it
spends his time like decrypting stuff um
because I was doing this in my home
directory which is encrypted cool um
this is a little hard to read though
because I'm like what is really
happening
I don't get it therefore be up lame
graphs flame graphs flame graphs are one
of my favorite things the way a flame
graph works is it means that you spend
all this time in this function and then
it called that function above it and it
called that function above it and it
called that function above it and then
it called equipped FS filled ear and
then that kind of like narrows up right
and if used you like the shape of how
your program is spending its time and
this is also like this isn't just a
first thing right this is like a
generally
a nice way to visualize performance
which I really love
I tried to looks get to set it a little
more here with this hand run flame grass
so you can imagine you spend like all of
your time in Maine and then 20% of the
time you go over the tanda function but
80% of the time you could alligator
I meant and as like and then I get again
like 10% like half of that is eating and
then like anyway
28% cheese I don't know um and flame
drafts don't just work with perks they
there's actually um these are all
generated by this tool called flame
graph yell by Brendan Gregg um and
there's a pretty simple input format and
a lot of like profiling libraries can
actually generate that format or you can
just make them do it it's really simple
um you just print out a stock trace and
put one at the end and then it will make
like a really pretty SVG with all these
like colors the colors don't really as
far as I can tell they don't mean
anything they just make it look like
fire and you can tell the things from
each other maybe they mean something I
don't know um the last thing that proof
can do is trace things like system calls
um
I'm mostly put this in because it's kind
of exciting and not cuz it actually
seems to work that well so there are a
few ways we talked about three ways to
trace events right this s trace is opens
new if there's perf trace there's
another thing called F trace but we're
not gonna talk about that cuz they I
don't understand it oh well that's the
main reason actually um so we're gonna
go poof trace so s trace lets you take a
process and see what system falls it's
writing first race also does this and it
does it quickly um but it also doesn't
work oh it's like sorry I lost all these
events that I'm like thanks I guess like
at least you're telling me I don't know
I thought I thought it could be a Strad
this but I also thought it was kind of
exciting because it's like nice to have
the things you want in the same tool but
I sort of I don't know I just did this
yesterday for the first time and then I
decided to put it in this talk okay
so yeah you can trace different things
like system calls and page faults and
scheduling events
um okay cool we still have a few more
minutes so we can tuck up more stuff
great um so we touch it and grab before
and hand grab plus you look at your
network traffic I mean I really love
looking at network traffic because like
I work for things that are on the
internet right
and it's this like super great interface
a lot of the network analysis tools are
extremely good um so it's really fun to
be able to take advantage of them
to figure out what you're so like one
one one one thing I really like to do is
let's say I'm on a computer and
something is like all these Network
requests are slow and you're like well
whose fault is that right because it
could be the clients fault the client
could be like sending the request but
then like taking a really long long time
did you serialize it or it could be like
the server's fault and the server could
be responding slowly um and you might
not really trust like the metrics
frameworks on either side I'm so one
nice thing to do is just like drop down
into like looking at the network
conversations I mean like well how long
did it really take right from the fine
from the time you sent the first packet
to the time you sent the last packet and
then like no one gets to mess with the
data right I mean kind of like you can
have like a single source of truth cuz
like the network is really nice
abstraction there so it's I like to do
this with TCP dump and Wireshark i'm tcp
dump is a program that i was scared of
for a very long time like maybe two
years and then i realized i was like oh
i can just save network traffic with tcp
dump and i don't need to worry about how
it works um maybe I can show you why I
was scared of TCP dump for a second so
this is why because I was like what is
happening wait why does it say wait oh
my god like like AK one win 992 options
not not anyway so it turns out that
chief enuf is still useful to me even
though I understand almost nothing in in
the effort of that program and the
reason is that you can just use TCP dump
to save network traffic to analyze later
um one really amazing thing about TCP
dump and about I Pig late network
analysis in general um is for basically
all of these tools you can give it a
filter and you're like I only want
traffic on port 80
um this is called the Berkeley packet
filter um or like BPF um and it's it's
really nice language it's super fast so
like maybe if you have like an extremely
fast network card um you have to worry
about running it in production but
generally I'd feel fine about like we're
gonna get in production as long as I
don't write too much less to disk and
you can just be like hey this is the
traffic I'm interested in please like
save it for me
you can filter you can filter out a lot
of stuff the filters are fast to
compiled into like magic pixie dust or
something and um it's really wonderful
and it saves it into a pcap file so pcap
is like magical chocolate chip cookies
for packet analysis which means that
like every tool understands pcap files
and they're wonderful and they can just
save this file and copy at your laptop
and like peruse it at your leisure um
this is a really great pattern like
tools like cystic also use this right
you just like save what's happening and
then you go and analyze it later when
you have like time and it's not like an
incident in your like you can calm down
oh yeah and BBF thought those are like
pretty easy to write you just like
source IP this oh no it's IP circ anyway
I always get the order of those two
things rohan but the cool thing is it's
either source IV or IP circ and then
yeah you just like try both and then it
works
um yeah seems really like source IP this
and on port 8080 and then it just works
um great you can also just like print
packets to your screen but TCP them like
you can be like and then this is kind of
like sometimes including
incomprehensible but sometimes you can
read the contents of the packet and
you'll understand something like if I go
to a web site like that no no it's not
there is too much noise okay that was
bad demo that's what happens when you
embed demos on the spot okay cool I'm
mr. gonna dick talked about Wireshark
for five seconds and then we're gonna be
done um so why are you sure cos packet
analysis tool which looks like this I
kind of love it I do not love what it
looks like at the beginning
this is confusing cuz there's all this
stuff kind of it's easy right but it's
actually okay and where our shark is
actually think that you can use if you
look kind of like close your eyes and
squinted at sideways and learn a few
basic things about it so one thing that
you can do I wrote like these like
exercises for using wireshark at some
point I want to be like it's okay I
promise
so you can just like search all your
packets and I was like okay I just want
the ones that have get in them and it
was like oh they were five and I was
like oh five five is a normal number and
I'm like oh they came from this IP and
they went to that IP and that's it and I
was like oh that's so simple and the
nice thing about this is like this
packet actually has like an HTTP request
in it and Wireshark knows everything
about the HTTP protocol and you can just
go into it and see what happens um
another really thing of nice thing about
Wireshark is that it knows what other
protocols and not just HTTP so if you're
talking to a database like [ __ ] for
instance um it would be like I know what
you're trying to query
I understand queries and you're like who
are you are you a magician and it'll be
like yeah and why it's like I am like a
magical shark that knows everything
about networking and you're like oh
goodness good thing you're on my side so
like why are you sure cuz you look great
and it's kind of confusing um but that's
cuz it's really powerful and if you if
you kind of like explore and click on
things it it often works at um this is a
neat thing you can do because I don't
like statistics and conversations this
is like the worst screenshot in the
universe and I'm sorry
but all the way on the right here there
are these numbers that tell you how long
the whole request was so it's like that
one took 0.5 seconds um and I like
sometimes like download a few cap file
and then like say Wireshark please tell
me how long everything took and then
it's like every the slowest thing was
like 3 milliseconds and I'm like Oh
everything's fine I get it
like my other metrics thing was wrong um
yeah um so I guess my messages in this
talk are like if you learn your
operating system tools you can you bug
all kinds of programs that are in like
every programming languages one thing
that happened two months is I was
sitting in a room and someone was like
Julia I have like a network performance
problem and I was like ok sounds fun and
they were like it's an ER Lang and I was
like ok
sounds fun and I don't know anything
about Erlang but Iran s trace on it and
then it was like blah blah blah LOC and
I was like lock lock is bad and I was
like you have a lock problem and they
were like yes I met me when and they
fixed the lock problem and then the
program was fast and I was like I'm
amazing so and so you you too can be a
wizard right and a lot of this stuff
really isn't that hard to learn like it
takes some time and some like
experimentation and sometimes you're
like what like why is it weird and what
is a packet but you can totally learn
all of it um one thing that I did to
help people learn it is I wrote a zine
called Linux debugging tools yellower on
love with a really cute penguin on the
cover my friend drew the really cute
penguin but I wrote the rest of it and
and it goes through a lot of the stuff
and like how you use it um I hope that
you'll read it it is at Kevin's dossier
slash Xian's thank you